ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER FOR BATH
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY.
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE
[inaudible]
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA REVEREND
OSHA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO WE'RE
TEACHING ASK OUT RELIGIOUS AWARD
CLASS.
AS WE NEAR THE END OF THE TEN
CLASS SESSIONS THE STUDENTS WERE
NOW READY TO EXPLORE THE CONCEPT
OF THE MIDDLE PATH.
VIEWED LITERALLY IT IS SIMPLY
THE PATH OF NON EXTREMES.
BUT THE MIDDLE PATH IS SO MUCH
MORE.
AFTER SHARING A NUMBER OF
EXAMPLES OF THIS DYNAMIC IN THE
LEASE OF TEACHING OF THE MIDDLE
PATH.
MY HUSBAND BOB ASKED THE CLASS
OF ABOUT TWENTY OR SO SECOND AND
THIRD GRADERS IF THEY HAD ANY
EXAMPLES TO SHARE.
THE HAND OF NINE YEAR OLD JOHN
ITO FROM PANDERING SHOT UP.
HE WAS INVITED TO COME UP TO THE
WHITE BOARD FOR HIS EXAMPLE
WOULD BE ADDED TO THE ONES
ALREADY WRITTEN ON THE BOARD.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED?
WHAT WOULD BE?
AT ONE OF WHAT WOULD BE AT ONE
EXTREME HE SAID.
LIVING FOREVER.
I THOUGHT.
THAT'S CERTAIN THE EXTREME.
THEN HE WAS ASKED.
WHAT IS AT THE OPPOSITE END?
HE SAID.
NEVER HAVING LIVED.
WHEN ASKED WHAT WILL BE THE
MIDDLE PATH?
HE REPLIED SIMPLY.
LIVING NOW.
THAT MIGHT BE ONE OF THE BEST
EXAMPLES OF MIDDLE PATH I HAVE
EVER HEARD.
THE UNDENIABLE WISDOM FROM NINE
YEAR OLD JOHN ITO.
REMAINS A GREAT REMINDER TO NOT
JUST LIVE THIS MOMENT OF LIFE.
BUT TO LOVE THIS MOMENT OF LIFE.
FOR EACH MOMENT QUICKLY PASSES
NEVER TO COME AGAIN.
NUMBER MENDOZA SAID WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND ASHA.
YEAH ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AS SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MAY SECOND
TWENTY NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT
NINE AM.
ON LOWER BACK OF OUR QUE HAN IS
IT'S SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE
MISTER CALDERON MOVES IN MISTER
FOUR SECONDS THAT THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE
.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ARE ABSENCES TODAY
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS OR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA.
ABSENCES FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BURKE
AND FRIEDMAN.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HIS ARIAN.
MATHIS AND STONE IS HAVE GUESTS
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU
ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COOPER WEBER
AND MEDINA TO SPEAKING IN GERMAN
IN MEMORY TODAY AT WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
I MOVE TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
SIXTY THREE TO ALLOW ALL BILLS
HEARD BY THE PREPARATIONS
COMMITTEE THIS WEEK AND REPORTED
TO THE DESK TODAY ON FRIDAY MAY
SEVENTEENTH MONDAY MAY TWENTIETH
OR TUESDAY.
MAY TWENTY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WITH A RECOMMENDATION
OF DO PASS AS AMENDED THE ORDER
TO THE SECOND READING FILE ONE
LEGISLATIVE DAY PRIOR TO THE
PRIOR TO THE DAY REQUIRED UNDER
THE ASSEMBLY RULES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I MOVE TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO A THE FOLLOWING NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THEIR
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE UPON
GERMAN OF SESSION TODAY TO HEAR
BILLS THAT WERE PLACED ON THE
SPENDS FILE.
AT THEIR HEARING YESTERDAY AS
PREVIOUSLY NOTICED IN THE DAILY
FILE THE LIST OF BILLS AT THE
DESK.
THE CLERK WILL BE THE BILLS.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE OTHER
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM ONE OH EIGHT
A. B. ELEVEN NINETY NINE
PETRIE-NORRIS FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FURTHER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO THIS POINT
SUSPEND THE RULES. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
NORRIS TO TAKE UP WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE A BE ELEVEN
NINETY NINE FORMALLY ITEM NUMBER
ONE AWAY ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
NOW THE CLERK WILL READ THE
BILLS.
THAT WE ARE MOVING TO SUSPEND
ACCORDING ROLE JOINT SIXTY TWO A
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE GONZALEZ AS
LABEL TEN DAVID CHIU ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR BURKE.
ASSEMBLE THIRTY NINE MURATSUCHI
AS I'M ABLE ONE TWENTY THREE
MCCARTY AS A MIDDLE ONE THIRTY
SIX QUIRK SILVA AS UNABLE ONE
FORTY ONE COOPER.
AS I'M ABLE ONE SIXTY ONE SEEING.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NINETY FIVE
PATTERSON IS ABLE TO SIXTY FIVE
CHOI AS AN ABLE TO SIXTY SIX
CHOI.
AS LEGAL FOR A FIVE BLANCA RUBIO
AS A MODEL FOR TWENTY THREE
GLORIA.
THE MIDDLE FOR TWENTY SEVEN BRO
AS A MIDDLE FOR EIGHTY SALAS HAS
ENABLE FIVE OH EIGHT KANSEN CHU
IS ABLE FIVE TWELVE TEACHING
ASSEMBLE FIVE FIFTEEN MATHIS AS
THE MIDDLE FIVE THIRTY SIX
FRAZIER.
IS SIMILAR FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
REYES HAS LABEL SIX TWENTY SEVEN
FRAZIER SYMBOL SIX FORTY ONE
FRAZIER IS ABLE SIX FIFTY HELLO
AS I'M ABLE SIX EIGHTY THREE
CARILLO.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTEEN WOULD
ASSEMBLE SEVEN FORTY FIVE
PETRIE-NORRIS AS A MOBILE SEVEN
FIFTY THREE EDUARDO GARCIA
SYMBOL SEVEN SIXTY THREE GRAY.
AS UNABLE SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
WICKS AS UNABLE SEVEN SEVENTY
EDUARDO GARCIA S. UNABLE SEVEN
EIGHTY BRO IS UNABLE SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR MULLIN HAS LABEL.
SEVEN NINETY ONE GABRIEL EXAMPLE
EIGHT TWELVE FRAZIER IS ABLE
EIGHT THIRTEEN FRAZIER AS I WILL
EIGHT TWENTY SIX REYES.
AS LEGAL EIGHT FORTY NINE BONTA
AS LABEL EIGHT FIFTY FOUR MAYES
EXAMPLE EIGHT NINETY WOULD AT
SOME ABLE NINE FOURTEEN HOLDEN.
UNTIL NINE THIRTY SIX ROBERT
RIVAS AS A RULE NINE THIRTY
EIGHT ROBERT RIVAS ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE THOUSAND AND ONE SEEING.
A SINGLE TEN TWENTY SEVEN BURKE
IS ABLE TEN SIXTY SIX GONZALEZ
ASSEMBLE TEN SIXTY SEVEN BIGELOW
AS ABLE TEN EIGHTY GONZALEZ.
AS UNABLE LEVIN'S FUNNY
CUNNINGHAM ASSEMBLE LEVIN --
TWENTY TWO WHEN ASSEMBLY BILL
LIMóN THIRTY SIX NAZARIAN A
SAMPLE LETTER THIRTY SEVEN IS
ARIAN ASSEMBLE LEVIN FORTY MARK
STONE.
IS I'M A LEVIN FIFTY SIX EDUARDO
GARCIA ASSEMBLE LEVIN SIXTY TWO
KALRA AS AN ABLE LEVIN SIXTY
NINE FRAZIER ASSEMBLE LEVIN
SEVENTY FIVE WOULD.
ASSEMBLE TWELVE TWENTY TWO FLORA
IS ABLE -- TWELVE FORTY TWO WHEN
A SINGLE TOLL FORTY NINE
MAIENSCHEIN A SINGLE TWELVE
FIFTY NINE THREE OF US A SYMBOL
TWELVE SIXTY EIGHT RODRIGUEZ AS
A MULTIPLE SEVENTY FIVE SANTIAGO.
AS IT WILL THIRTEEN TWELVE LOW
SINGLE THIRTEEN SEVENTEEN BRO AT
SYMBOL THIRTEEN FORTY DAVID CHIU
S. ABOUT THIRTY FORTY ONE BERMAN.
ASSEMBLE THIRTY FORTY TWO LOW AS
I WILL THIRTEEN FORTY THREE
EIGHT MEN.
AS I'M ABLE THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR
BARRICADE HAND ASSEMBLE THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX MEDINA IS ABLE
THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO O'DONNELL IS
ABLE THIRTY SIXTY THREE MARK
STONE.
AS ABLE THIRTEEN SIXTY FOUR
BLOCK A RUBIO THE SAME --
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX DOLLARS
ASSEMBLED THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
WICKS A SYMBOL THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE BONTA ASSEMBLE FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN BLANCA RUBIO.
A SYMBOL FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
MARK STONE ASSEMBLE.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN TEN A
SIMILAR FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
MCCARTY ISN'T ABLE FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE GRAY.
AS I'M ABLE FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIXTEEN ASSEMBLE FIFTEEN OH NINE
MULLIN.
AS SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
FRIEDMAN A SIMPLE FIFTY TWENTY
FOUR DAVID CHIU ASSEMBLE FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO BLANCA RUBIO.
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SIX CALDERON ASSIGNABLE FIFTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT GLORIA AS ABILITY
NINETY BLANCA RUBIO ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN OH SIX GRAY.
A SYMBOL SIXTEEN ELEVEN DAVID
CHIU ESSENTIAL SIXTEEN TWENTY
SANTIAGO.
ASSEMBLE SIXTEEN FORTY TWO WOULD
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE
CARILLO.
AS ABLE SEVENTY TWENTY SIX OUR
BONTA AS A SYMBOL SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE BOERNER HORVATH.
SOME ABLE SEVENTY THIRTY FOUR
DAVID CHIU AS ABLE SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE DAVID CHIU AND
ASSEMBLE SEVENTEEN SEVENTY SIX
LEVINE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE THE ASSEMBLY SECOND READING
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 594-362-6640
772-987-31190 FIVE ELEVEN NINETY
SEVEN THIRTY NO ONE FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
TO A 1-762-825-8729
489-811-05410 891-160-1240.
EIGHT TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN TWELVE
SIXTY NINE FORTINO 614-561-56016
431-640-41820 THREE EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FOUR AND EIGHTEEN THIRTY
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO WILL BE
CONTINUED
.
MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY I'LL ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT AB SIX FORTY
FRAZIER THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE SIX FORTY BY
SEPTEMBER FRAZIER AND ACTUALLY
THE SEX CRIMES.
MR FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SIX
FORTY EXPANDS TRAINING COURSES
FOR DISTRICT ATTORNEYS. TO
REQUIRE TRAINING ON THE INS
INVESTIGATION AND PASTA.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE MR FRAZIER
ATTENTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
ON THE INVESTIGATION OR
PROSECUTION OF SEXUAL ABUSE
CASES INVOLVING VICTIMS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES ARE SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED AT A RATE SEVEN TIMES
HIGHER THAN THOSE WITHOUT
DISABILITIES.
SB SIX FORTY WILL EQUIP OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO ADDRESS THE
EPIDEMIC.
OF VIOLENCE AGAINST THE ID DE
COMMUNITY.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED BROAD
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
ALL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES SIXTY NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY TWO A.
B. THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY
THREE BY SOMETHING MEMBER WICKS
AND ACTUALLY THE SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES.
MISS WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER -- AND FELLOW
COLLEAGUES CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
ARE CRUCIAL TO OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM BY PROVIDING HEALTH
NUTRITION AND ECONOMIC SUPPORTS
TO STUDENTS.
ALTHOUGH CLASSIFIED WORK IS
COMPLETED BY THE SAME STANDARDS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER DISTRICT
IS MERIT OR NON MERIT NON MERIT
DISTRICTS HAVE A LONGER
PROBATIONARY PERIOD OF ONE YEAR
WHERE IS AMERICA DISTRICT ALLOWS
FOR SIX MONTH PROBATIONARY
PERID.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY THREE WILL
BRING CONFORMITY AND CLARITY FOR
K. THROUGH TWELVE CLASSIFIED
STUFF.
BY ALLOWING FOR CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES AND NON MERIT
DISTRICTS TO OBTAIN PERMANENT
STATUS NO LATER THAN SIX MONTHS.
MANY NON MERIT DISTRICTS ALREADY
CONFORM TO THE MERIT DISTRICT
TIME LIMITS DUE TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS.
ALIGNING BOTH OF THESE CODES
SIMPLIFIES THE PROCESS ALIGNING
BOTH OF THESE CODES MAKES AS
MUCH EASIER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WAX.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
HI MOM MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
ARE [inaudible]
YEAH.
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TELEVOTES EYES FORTY ONE NEWS
FOURTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN NINETY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO BUSINESS.
MISS WHICH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY WILL HELP LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES BY REQUIRING MORE
TRANSPARENCY.
FROM ALL MARKET PLACES.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN MARKET
PLACES IN THIRD PARTY SELLERS
WHICH INCLUDE A LOT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES IS CRITICAL THE
SELLER'S ABILITY TO REACH
CUSTOMERS.
AND GENERATE REVENUE.
AB SEVENTY NINETY WILL ENSURE
THERE'S TRANSPARENCY AND WILL
REQUIRE EAT -- MARKET PLACES TO
DRAFT PLANS -- DRAFT TERMS AND
CONDITIONS IN PLAIN INTELLIGIBLE
LANGUAGE MAKE IT EASILY
AVAILABLE FOR ONLINE MARKETPLACE
SELLERS.
AND SAID THE GROUNDS FOR
DECISIONS TO RETAIN A REFUSE TO
DISTRIBUTE FUNDS IN ITS PROCESS
PENDING INVESTIGATION OR
RESOLUTION OF DISPUTE.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ARE SAFE
SIMILAR TO REGULATIONS THAT WERE
RECENTLY APPROVED BY THE
EUROPEAN UNION IT WILL GO INTO
EFFECT NEXT YEAR.
THIS HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
IS CO AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM.
AND IS RECEIVE SUPPORT FROM THE
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY THE
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION THE
GROCERS AND MANY OTHERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WORK MISTER
CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE BRIEFLY IN
SUPPORT AS A PROD CO AUTHOR THIS
MEASURE.
A HAPPY TO COLLABORATE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY --
MEMBERS THIS BILL WILL LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE ONLINE MARKET
PLACE IT'S A GOOD BILL AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN AB SEVEN ELEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN ELEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER DAVID CHIU AND
EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE RECORDS.
MR TO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES THIS IS A
SIMPLE BILL THE COKE TO CLOSE A
GAP IN THE LAW. FOR SOME IN OUR
LGBTQ COMMUNITY IT WILL ENSURE
THAT TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY
PEOPLE HAVE GRADUATED FROM
SCHOOL CAN UPDATE ALL DIPLOMAS
TRANSCRIPTS R. G. D.'S TO
REFLECT THEIR CORRECT LEGAL NAME
AND GENDER.
DIPLOMAS OR TRANSCRIPTS THAT ARE
NOT UPDATED CAN CREATE
CHALLENGES APPLYING FOR COLLEGE
GRADUATES SCORE EMPLOYMENT WE'VE
HEARD STORIES OF INDIVIDUALS
WERE OUTED AFTER SUPERVISOR SAW
AN INCORRECT NAME.
ON AN OUTDATED EDUCATION
DOCUMENT WHILE CURRENT STUDENTS
HAVE THIS RIGHT THE BILL WOULD
CLOSE THE GAP IN LAW FOR FORMER
STUDENTS WHO MAY HAVE TRANSITION
OR COME OUT AFTER LEAVING SCHOOL.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOOSE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
LONG MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE EYES
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE THREE
THIRTY SEVEN WE PASS AND RETAIN
FILE ITEMS THIRTY NINE TO FORTY
ONE WE PASSED A RETAINED.
FILE ITEMS FORTY THREE THROUGH.
FORTY NINE WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN FILE ITEMS FIFTY THREE
SIXTY FIVE WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM SIXTY SIX TO SEVENTY
TWO WILL BE PASSED THE RETAINED.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR THROUGH
SEVENTY SIX WE PASSED A RETAIN
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT WE
PASSED A RETAINED.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY NINE
AB TEN EIGHTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN EIGHTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
ACTUALLY THE REAL ESTATE
APPRAISAL.
MR FRAZIER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
A. B. TEN EIGHTEEN SIMPLY
CODIFIES AT HOME PRAZERES MUST
STAY WITHIN THEIR SCOPE OF
PRACTICE WHEN DETERMINING.
A HOME VALUATION THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT OF
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE THE
CHIME DIDN'T WORK BUT WE'RE VOTE
AND ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
LONG MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO.
ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
FILE I'M AT WILL BE PASSED
RETAIN THIS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE
A. B. TWELVE NINETY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
AS LEGAL TWELVE NINETY ONE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND ACTUALLY THE CANNABIS.
MISTER JONES ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWELVE NINETY ONE CLARIFIES THE
TIME FRAME FOR WOULD CANNABIS
BUSINESSES.
NEED TO COMPLY WITH LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT REQUIREMENTS IT LABOR
PEACE AGREEMENT IS AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE BUSINESS AND A LABOR
ORGANIZATION THAT PRESCRIBED
OBLIGATION OF EACH PARTY'S.
THESE AGREEMENTS TEND TO INCLUDE
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL PROVISIONS
THAT PROTECT BUSINESS AND
EMPLOYEES.
AB TWELVE NINETY ONE WILL
CLARIFY THAT BUSINESSES WITH
TWENTY EMPLOYEES ARE MORE NEED
TO ENTER LABOR PEACE AGREEMENT
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OR PULLING
THEIR TWENTIETH EMPLOYEE.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY SIX
KNOWS FOURTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY BY
SOMETHING MEMBER OBERNOLTE AND
ACTUALLY THE CANNABIS MR
OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
HAS ESTABLISHED LICENSING FEES
FOR THE CULTIVATION AND SALE OF
CANNABIS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
WOULD CODIFY THOSE FEES IN STATE
LAW THIS ACTION WOULD ESTABLISH
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER THOSE
FEES AS WE HAVE WITH OVER 90% OF
THE FEES IN THE APARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE OF A
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
NINE KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTY THREE AND
EIGHTY FOUR WE PASSED IN RETAINS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE
AB EIGHTEEN OH FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN OH FIVE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT AND ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT.
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN OH FIVE IS A LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE BILL WHICH
MAKES MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES
THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
PROVISIONS OF THE LABOR CODE.
THESE TECHNOLOGY CHANGES OR
BRING THE LANGUAGE ALONG WITH
FEDERAL OSHA STANDARDS INCREASED
UNIFORMITY IN THE LABOR CODE.
THESE CHANGES ARE NEEDED BECAUSE
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN FEDERAL
OSHA AMENDED IS SUPPORTING
REGULATION TO CHANGE THE TYPE OF
TO CHANGE THE TYPE OF WORK
RELATED INJURIES AND EMPLOYERS
MUST REPORT.
ANY STATE WITH ITS OWN OSHA
PLANTS SUCH AS CALIFORNIA MUST
MAKE THE NECESSARY CHANGES O
CONFORM TO THE FEDERAL OSHA
REPORTING REGULATIONS.
THIS BILL THIS BILL PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF COMMITTEE AND
I RESPECT THE HOUSE WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MOM MEMBERS GO TO ESIRE TO VOTE.
MOM MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
TWO KNOWS ELEVEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES
.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTY SIX THROUGH
NINETY WILL BE PASSED TO RETAIN
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINETY ONE
AB ELEVEN THIRTY TO THE CLERK
WILL READ.
A CYNICAL LEVIN THIRTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL.
MR GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB ELEVEN THIRTY TWO WHICH IS UP
FOR MEMBERS TO TODAY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NO.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED THE BILL WILL GO OUT TO
PRINT IT BACK TO FILE.
MOVING TO AB.
ELEVEN NINETY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN NINETY NINE
FIVE FAMILY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AND ACTUALLY THE STATE REAL
PROPERTY.
THIS FEATURE NORTH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER NUMBERS
I RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB ELEVEN NINETY
NINE THIS IS A DISTRICT BELL
RELATED TO THE FAIRVIEW
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
WHICH IS LOCATED IN THE HEART OF
ORANGE COUNTY AND THE HEART OF
MY DISTRICT.
YOUR VIEW IS THE LAST REMAINING
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER IN THE
STATE AND OVER THE COURSE OF THE
COMING YEAR.
DDS IS PLANNING TO RELOCATE THE
CURRENT RESIDENCE TO COMMUNITY
HOMES AND I PLANNING THE CLOSURE
AT FAIRVIEW AS WE ANTICIPATE THE
CLOSURE OF THIS HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN ACRE PROPERTY.
AND PLAN FOR THE FUTURE USE OF
FAIRVIEW I HAVE THREE PRIORITIES
FIRST TO ENSURE THAT THE NEEDS
OF THE DD COMMUNITY ARE BEING
RESPECTED AND ADDRESSED.
BOTH NOW AND IN THE FUTURE TO
THAT WE ARE WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE AND
WITH LOCAL ELECTED AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE.
AND INTEGRATED PLAN FOR WHAT
THIS PROPERTY COULD BECOME AND
THREE THAT WE INSURE THAT WE'RE
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP ACROSS.
ORANGE COUNTY.
THIS IS A HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
ACRES AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THERE'S
NO SHORTAGE OF EXCITING IDEAS
FOR WHAT THIS PROPERTY COULD BE.
AND WE REALLY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET SOME OF THE
STATE AND THE REGION'S MOST
PRESSING NEEDS.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY AS SOME OF
THAT THE PROPOSAL'S INCLUDE A
SATELLITE CAMPUS FOR A LOCAL
UNIVERSITY OR COLLEGE.
THE SECOND LOCATION FOR MIND YOU
SEE A MENTAL HEALTH AND WELLNESS
HAD WHICH WILL SERVE ORANGE
COUNTY.
AND THIRD EIGHT EXTENSIVE ARRAY
OF HOUSING PROPOSALS INCLUDING.
HOUSING FOR THE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED COMMUNITY PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR FACULTY
AND STUDENTS IT'S AN AS SOME OF
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN JUST YESTERDAY.
THE LA TIMES REPORTED THAT ONE
IN TEN OF OUR CSU STUDENTS ARE
HOMELESS.
THAT IS AN URGENT AND PRESSING
CRISIS AND AS I SAID I THINK
FAIR VIEW CAN BE PART OF
ADDRESSING THAT.
AND SO MUCH MORE IF YOU TOWN
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THIS I THE
BILL HAS ENJOYED A AT YOU NONE
OF THIS VOTE IN COMMITTEE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE HERE ON THE FLOOR TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS BETWEEN OURS
MISTER FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK ON THIS
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY FOR THE
MEMBERS AND AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE RATE STUDY CAME OUT AT
THE END OF MARCH.
AND THE ID COMMUNITIES BEEN
UNDER FUNDED BY ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS.
AND THAT'S PROBABLY A LOW BALL
ESTIMATE.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE RESOURCES
THAT HAVE BEEN EXPENDED ON
BEHALF OF THE ID POPULATION?
THESE ARE THINGS THAT I THINK
THAT SHOULD AUTOMATICALLY BE
REINVESTED.
IN THIS POPULATION.
WE LOOK AT HOW WE'VE UNDERFUNDED.
FOR DECADES.
THIS UNDERSERVED AND UNDER
FUNDED THE POPULATION GOING
FORWARD.
THE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE IS WITH THE
DEMISE OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS.
IS IT'S CREATED AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR INCLUSION IN THE COMMUNITIES
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS BUT AT
WHAT COST.
THESE ONE TIME BECAUSE SHOULD BE
ABSORBED.
IN THIS KIND OF OPPORTUNITY I
APPRECIATE.
THE AUTHOR TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S NO.
FUNNY BUSINESS WITH THE MONEY
BEING SLID INTO THE GENERAL FUND
OR UTILIZED IN OTHER AREAS BUT
MEMBERS.
I ABSOLUTELY IMPLORE YOU TO
REMEMBER.
AFTER LOOKING AT THIS BUDGET AND
WHAT HAS HAPPENED WITH THE
POPULATION GOING FORWARD.
UNDERSTANDING THAT TARGETED
ARGUMENTATION OVER THE PAST
YEARS.
WE STILL HAVE INCREASED OUR
POPULATION BY.
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS.
AND STILL DON'T ACCOMMODATE THEM
AT A LEVEL THAT THEY DESERVE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
THIS BILL.
BUT WITH CAUTION. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS MONEY FOR THESE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTERS IS USED
APPROPRIATELY TO PROP UP THE
POPULATION THAT IS SERVED.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
MISS BETWEEN ARSENIC CLOSE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM OAKLEY FOR OFFERING THAT
PERSPECTIVE AND FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU HAVE DONE OVER SO MANY
YEARS.
FOR THE ID DE COMMUNITY I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOU THAT
AND AS I SAID IN MY OPENING WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT AS FOR
PLANNING FOR THE FUTURE AT THIS
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER OR INDEED.
FOR ANY OF THE OTHER PROPERTIES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY BEING
DISCUSSED THAT WE HI THE OF
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE IS INSURING
THAT BUT THE SHORT AND THE LONG
TERM NEEDS.
AT THE TD COMMUNITY OUR ADDRESS
AND THAT IS CERTAINLY A PART OF
OF MY OBJECTIVE AND I THINK.
PART OF THE OBJECTIVE THAT THE
COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE SO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
ENSURE THAT THAT BECOMES A
REALITY FOR THIS PROPERTY AND
FOR OTHERS ACROSS THE STATE.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AFFECT.
THANK YOU THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NINETY TWO WILL BE
PASSED AND RETAINS.
MOVING TO GUEST INTRODUCTIONS
MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FROM THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER FOR
YOUR GUEST INTERACTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT'S MY
GREAT HONOR.
TO WELCOME PARKER BOSWELL AND
HIS FAMILY FROM BY SO YOU TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. TO RECOGNIZE HIM
AS THE TWENTY NINETEEN C. I. F.
SCHOLAR ATHLETE OF THE YEAR.
THE CALIFORNIA INTERSCHOLASTIC
FEDERATION IS A PROCEDURE
[inaudible]
PROGRAM.
THAT RECOGNIZES TO STUDENT
ATHLETES BASED ON EXCELLENCE IN
ATHLETICS ACADEMICS AND
CHARACTER.
PARKER BASEL IS A TWO SPORT
ATHLETE AT EL THE MONTE HIGH
SCHOOL INVITES CELAYA.
PARTICIPATING IN BASEBALL AND
FOOTBALL ALL FOUR YEARS WHILE
ALSO SERVING AS TEAM CAPTAIN FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS.
HE HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
THE SCHOOL STUDENT GOVERNMENT.
AND IS CURRENTLY SERVING AS
THEIR PRESIDENT.
PARKER HAS AN IMPRESSIVE. THREE
POINT NINE THREE GPA.
AND WILL BE ATTENDING CHAPMAN
UNIVERSITY IN THE FALL WITH A
FULL RIDE ACADEMIC SCHOLARSHIP.
TEACHERS DESCRIBE PARKER IS AN
OUTSTANDING STUDENT.
AND AN EXCELLENT REPRESENTATIVE
OF ELDER MONTE HIGH SCHOOL.
HE IS THE KIND OF PERSON.
YOU WISH YOU HAD AS A TEAMMATE.
A FRIEND.
AND A SON.
CONGRADULATIONS PARKER.
ON BEING THE TWENTY NINETEEN CIF
SCHOLARSHIP ATHLETE OF THE YEAR
.
MISTER NAZARIAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR GUEST
INSTRUCTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
COLLEAGUES ON ON OCCASION YOU
HAVE HEARD FOR ME ABOUT MY
FAMILIES BACKGROUND AND FLIGHT --
AND THE PERIOD OF TIME THAT'S
TAKEN US TO TRAVEL FROM
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE WORLD
FINALLY SETTLING IN THE UNITED
STATES -- I IT GIVES ME GREAT
PLEASURE TODAY TO INTRODUCE
SOMEONE WHO IS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE REGION THAT MY
GRANDPARENTS.
WERE BORN AND RAISED IN AND
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO FLEE ONCE
THE CITY WAS BURNT THE CITY THAT
THEY WOULD LIVE THEN.
HAD TO BE WAS BURNED DOWN -- I
HAVE THE GREAT HONOR OF REPAIR
OF INTRODUCING.
DEPUTY FOREIGN MINISTER ARMENIA
ALEX ONION WHO IS -- THE MINUTES
THE DEPUTY FOREIGN MINISTER FOR
THE REPUBLIC OF ARTS UP -- SHE
AFTER HER COMPLETION OF STUDIES
IN ENGLISH AND GERMAN LANGUAGES
SHE RECEIVED HER MASTER'S DEGREE
FROM -- THE DIPLOMATIC ACADEMY
OF LONDON.
SHE'S HAD A PUBLIC SERVICE
CAREER STARTING.
FROM -- NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
HAVING WORKED AS THE THIS IS
SPECIAL ASSISTANT TO PRIME
MINISTER AND NOW TO WORKING HER
WAY TO THE DEPUTY PRIME PRIME
MINISTER I'M TAKE DEPUTY FOREIGN
MINISTER.
OF THE REPUBLIC OF ARTS UP GIVES
ME GREAT PLEASURE AND HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE HER ON THE FLOOR AND I
WELCOME YOU TO JOIN US FOR A
PICTURE THANK YOU
.
MR STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUEST INSTRUCTION IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS THE CALIFORNIANS ARE
SCHOLASTIC FEDERATION.
GETS HUNDREDS OF APPLICATIONS
EVERY YEAR FOR SCHOLAR ATHLETE
OF THE YEAR AND I WANT TO
PRESENT TO YOU GRACE BAILEY.
HI GRACE BAILEY IS.
A REALLY PRIME EXAMPLE OF ALL OF
THIS BECAUSE NOT ONLY.
IS SHE A STAR ATHLETE IN THREE
FIELDS AS TEAM CAPTAIN.
IN SOCCER AND CROSS COUNTRY AND
TRACK BUT SHE HAS HIRED NOW
BROUGHT MATH TUTORS TO HER
SCHOOL SHE'S CONSISTENTLY ON THE
DEAN'S LIST IN FACT.
ALL OF THE CRITERIA FOR THE CIA
THIS CIF AWARD GRACE IS LEFT FOR
IN YOUR REAR VIEW MIRROR JUST
LIKE SHE LEAVES HER COMPETITION
BEHIND ON THE FIELD AS SHE IT
LEADS THE SO CAL LIGHTS IN SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
CHOOSE FROM SO CAL HIGH SCHOOL
IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND SHE'S
HERE WITH HER FATHER AND HER
MOTHER AND HER GRANDMOTHER SO
PLEASE GIVE A WARM WELCOME TO
GRACE PALEY
.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEMS NINETY THREE
THROUGH ONE THIRTY FOUR DOES ANY
MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
ACTUALLY TO RETAIL FOOD
FACILITIES.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CALENDAR.
MOM MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY KNOWS.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
WE WILL DEFER READING OF THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
I MEMBERS I'M ORDERING THE
DESTINY HELD OPEN UNTIL TWELVE
NOON ON FRIDAY MAY SEVENTEENTH
TO RECEIVE COMMITTEE REPORTS.
ALL MEMBERS WE REQUEST YOUR
PROMPT ATTENDANCE ON MONDAY
SESSION MAY TWENTIETH TWENTY
NINETEEN FOR THE ASSEMBLY
PANORAMIC PHOTO.
FRIDAY MAY SEVENTEENTH THERE
WILL BE NO FLOOR SESSION IN NO
CHECK IN SUCH AN MONDAY MAY
TWENTIETH FLOOR SESSION IS A ONE
PM AGAIN PLEASE BE PROMPT.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PREPARATIONS
COMMITTEE WERE ASKED TO GO
DIRECTLY TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM.
WHEN THE CALL IS LIFTED?
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
CALL IS LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
PLEASE REPORT IMMEDIATELY. TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM
.
MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
.
ORDER IN THE THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON IN A
GERMAN MEMORY TODAY MR
MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR IN GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF COLONEL BOB
TING MEN WHO PASSED AWAY.
JUST RECENTLY SHORT OF HIS
NINETY SEVENTH BIRTHDAY HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS BELOVED WIFE OF
SEVENTY FOUR YEARS GâY.
AND IT'S CHILDREN BOB JUNIOR AND
SUSAN FOUR GRANDCHILDREN AND
FOUR GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
BOB WAS A FIXTURE IN THE SCRIPTS
RANCH COMMUNITY YOU COULD FIND
HIM EVERY YEAR AT THE FOURTH OF
JULY PARADE IN EVERY DECEMBER IS
THE GIRL SCOUTS LET THE CHAIR
BACK TREE.
HE WAS PROUD OF THE SCRIPTS
RANCH HIGH SCHOOL FALCONS AND
WOULD ASK THE SCORE OF EVERY
GAME ON SUNDAY MORNING.
BOB LOVE THE SCRIPTS RANCH
COMMUNITY DEEPLY HE'S ONE OF THE
FEW PEOPLE TO HAVE A PUBLIC
SCHOOL NAMED AFTER HIM.
IN THE STATE'S SECOND LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED.
EVERY YEAR MY OFFICE WOULD
PARTICIPATE WITH HIM ENDING MEN
DAY AT DINGMAN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL.
HIS SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY
STARTED IN WORLD WAR TWO AND DID
NOT STOP THERE HE SERVED IN THE
KOREAN AND VIETNAM WARS.
EARNING MULTIPLE HONORS THE
COLONEL WAS THE RECIPIENT OF
SEVERAL PURPLE HEARTS A SILVER
STAR SOLDIER'S MEDAL AND A
BRONZE STAR.
HE WAS INTRICATELY INVOLVED WITH
THE COMMUNITY FOR NEARLY FIFTY
YEARS HE HELPED PLAN THE
COMMUNITY OF SCRIPTS RANCH AS
THE NEIGHBORHOOD WAS GROWING IN
THE SEVENTIES.
AND HE SPOKE AT CITYCOUNCIL
MEETINGS AND SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS OFTEN HE WOULD COME
DOWN TO CITY HALL WEARING HIS
UNIFORM AND SHARE HOW MANY TIMES
HE HAD BEEN BEFORE THE COUNCIL.
AND I I HAVE TO TELL YOU
SOMEBODY WHO SAT ON THE CITY
COUNCIL WHEN -- GROUNDING MEN
WOULD COME DOWN I WAS ABOUT
THREE YEARS INTO MY TERM OUT
BEFORE I'D BEEN MORE CITY
COUNCIL MEETINGS AND BOB DAMON.
THERE WAS NOTHING THAT HE DIDN'T
PARTICIPATE IN WITH THE SCRIPTS
RANCH COMMUNITY I GOT TO WORK
WITH HIM FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS --
AND HE WAS A REMARKABLE MAN A
DECENT PERSON -- AND WE WILL
MISS HIS INCREDIBLE SMILE HIS
KIND HEARTS THAT WAS ALWAYS
HELPING OTHERS THANK YOU AND I
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN TODAY'S
MEETING IN MEMORY OF COLONEL BOB
TING.
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER GOOD MORNING TO
THEM JOINING IN MEMORY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS.
DR GEORGE DAVIS KING OF ELK
GROVE.
DOCTOR KING WAS WELL KNOWN ON
THE CAPITAL HAVING WORKED THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE MAJORITY
SERVICES FOR OVER TEN YEARS.
DOCTOR KING WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
CREATING CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
MASTER PLAN OF EDUCATION AND
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFETIME.
SERVED IN VARIOUS ROLES WE WAS
VERY INVOLVED IN THE BETTERMENT
OF EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA.
DOCTOR KING WAS A CARING LOVING
PERSON IT WILL BE TRULY MISSED.
MY HEARTFELT PRAYERS GOT DOCTOR
KING FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
DR KING IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
KATHRYN IT IS CHILDREN GEORGE
JUNIOR.
DAVID KEVIN ANTHONY RIGOROUS
STEVE.
AND JOHN.
IN BY SISTERS CLARA IN THE NORA.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER MESS
WEBER YOU ARE ALSO RECOGNIZED ON
THIS TO GERMAN MEMORY.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO RISE
IN -- AN ACID WOULD JOIN IN
MEMORY OF DOCTOR GEORGE KING --
GEORGE DAVIS CAME PASSED AWAY ON
MAY ELEVENTH TWENTY NINETEEN AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY EIGHT IT WAS A
LONG TIME CAPITOL STAFFER MEMBER.
HE SERVED ON AN OFFER VARIOUS
BUT AS PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT TO
MULTIPLE SPEAKERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
AND WAS ACTUALLY THE FIRST
CONSULTANT TO THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS. ONE INSPIRED A
VIRGINIA IN NINETEEN THIRTY ONE
DOCTOR KING EARNED HIS
BACHELOR'S AND MASTER'S DEGREE
FROM HOWARD UNIVERSITY.
AND HIS PHD FROM INDIANA
UNIVERSITY.
HE WENT ON TO TEACH THE HISTORY
AND H. B. C. USE FOR MANY YEARS
AND LATER BECAME CHAIR OF THE
AFRICANA STUDIES DEPARTMENT AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF MINNESOTA.
HE CAN HIS COMMITMENT TO
EDUCATION EQUITY WAS ALL ABOUT
WHAT HE WAS IN AND TRUSTED IN
HIS MIND TO DO.
HE SERVED IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES
IN WASHINGTON DC ON VARIOUS
INSTITUTES AND COMMITTEES
BASICALLY MAKING SURE THAT FOLKS
HAVE THE CORRECT INFORMATION
DEVELOPING RESOURCES.
AND TRAINING FACULTY
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT H. B. C.
USE.
IT'S INTERESTING WHEN I READ
ABOUT -- GEORGE DR KING AND I
HAVE THE GOOD FORTUNE OBVIOUSLY
OF MEETING HIM HERE AT THE
CAPITOL I I CAME TO UNDERSTAND
THAT HE AND I HAD SO MANY THINGS
ALIKE YOU SPEND ALL OF MOST OF
HIS LIFE AS A UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR.
WORKING IN THE FIELD OF AFRICANA
STUDIES BASICALLY DEVELOPING THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDIES
DEPARTMENT IN VARIOUS STATES AND
TRAINING AND AND ASSISTING YOUNG
SCHOLARS TO BECOME THE KIND OF
PROFESSIONALS NECESSARY TO
PROMOTE THE PROFESSION.
HE SERVED AS A WHITE HOUSE
FOLLOWED SEVERAL TIMES AND
CONFERENCES ON HANDICAPPING
CONDITIONS ANY WORK TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TRAINING TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY GROUPS
GRAPPLING WITH PROBLEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE SCHOOL
DESEGREGATION.
HE WAS CELEBRATED CIVIC EN L.
LEADER AND A SCHOLAR HE WAS
RECOGNIZED BY US IT'S A
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AS ONE OF OUR LEGIT
LIVING LEGENDS.
IN THE IN THE STATE IN TWENTY
ELEVEN THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
SUPERINTENDENTS AND
ADMINISTRATORS GAVE HIM A
LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT AWARD.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOR THE ETERNAL
FLAME PUBLIC SERVICE AWARD WAS
PRESENTED TO HIM BY OUR FORMER
SPEAKER HERB WESSON.
MOST RECENTLY HE WAS ACTIVE IN
SEVERAL COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING CHAIR BAY PACK
SACRAMENTAL AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
THE AND DOUBLE ACP.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS WE
OFFER LOVE AND CONDOLENCES TO
HIS WIFE OF THIRTY SIX YEARS
CATHARINE HIS CHILDREN
GRANDCHILDREN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN.
NIECES AND NEPHEWS AND ALL THOSE
WHO KNEW DR KING AND CALL HIM
FRIEND.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS HAS LOST A STRONG
SUPPORTER ONE WHO WAS ASSISTED
US IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CURRICULUM AND WHOSE HAS
CONTINUED TO WORK THROUGHOUT HIS
ENTIRE LIFE TO IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS.
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THE
FIELD OF EDUCATION HE WILL BE SO
REALLY MESSED WE RESPECT ASKED
THAT IS THAT WE ALL JOINED IN
MEMORY OF DOCTOR GEORGE KING.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF SHOSHANA GORIN.
WHO PASSED AWAY EARLIER THIS
MONTH?
SCORING TAUGHT AT MAGNOLIA
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN RIVERSIDE.
FOR OVER FIFTEEN YEARS.
SHE EARNED HER BACHELOR'S DEGREE
AND TEACHING CREDENTIAL FROM SAN
DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY.
MISS MORE GORE AND MOVED TO
RIVERSIDE AND TWO THOUSAND TO
PURSUE HER TEACHING CAREER.
WHILE TEACHING AT MAGNOLIA
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL SHE TOOK
EVENING CLASSES AT CAL STATE SAN
BERNARDINO.
WHERE SHE EARNED HER MASTER'S
DEGREE?
SHE WAS LOVED AND RESPECTED BY
HER STUDENTS AND CO WORKERS.
SHOSHANA'S PASSION FOR THE
TEACHING PROVIDE PROFESSION.
ILLUSTRATED ITSELF IN THE CARE
AND CONCERN THAT SHE SHARED.
FOR ALL HER CLASSES AS WELL AS
OUR FELLOW TEACHERS.
SHE WAS ESPECIALLY WELL KNOWN
FOR HER ACTIVE INVOLVEMENT IN
THE TEACHERS UNION AS WELL AS
ENGAGING CLASSROOM.
ECONOMY USING GORE IN BOX HER
MEMORY BURNS BRIGHT IN THE
HEARTS OF THOSE SHE INSPIRED.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER TWO SONS
AND THREE GRANDCHILDREN.
HER FAMILY MOURNS THE LOSS OF
THE TREMENDOUS MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER FRIEND AND TEACHER I
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED THE JOURNAL
ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
THE CLERK WILL NOW READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AS THE MIDDLE THREE FORTY NINE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SIMPLE FOR FORTY
SIX I SEVENTY NO ZERO SOME
PEOPLE FIVE NINETY I SEVENTY
KNOWS HEROES UNABLE SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT I SEVENTY NO ZERO AS LEGAL
SEVEN SEVENTY NINE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO A SINGLE. EIGHT FORTY NINE
SEVENTY NO ZERO AS LEGAL EIGHT
NINETY TWO I SEVENTY NO ZERO A
SINGLE NINE FORTY NINE HIGHS
SEVENTY NO ZERO SOME REAL NINE
FIFTY SEVEN I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SINGLE TEN TWENTY SIX SIZE
SEVENTY NO ZERO SINGLE ELEVEN
SIXTY ONE I SEVENTY NO.
ZERO SOME PEOPLE LIVE IN SIXTY
FOUR EYES SEVENTY NO ZERO SAME
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX FIVE SEVENTY NO
ZERO NINE ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT I SEVENTY
NO SERIOUSLY ABLE TOLD NINETY I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SINGLE TWELVE
NINETY NINE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SINGLE. THIRTEEN ELEVEN I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SINGLE THIRTEEN
FIFTY TÁI SEVENTY NO ZERO A
SINGLE THIRTEEN SEVENTY I
SEVENTY NO ZERO LABEL THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SIX I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SYMBOL THIRTEEN SEVENTY NINE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SINGLE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR EYES SEVENTY NO.
ZERO SINGLE FOURTEEN NINETY
SEVEN I SEVENTY NO ZERO CIVIL
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE SEVENTY NO
ZERO AS LITTLE FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE
I SEVENTY NO ZERO SYMBOL FIFTEEN
SEVENTY THREE I SEVENTY KNOWS
THEIR OWN SINGLE SIXTEEN SIXTY
SIX I SEVENTY NO ZERO A SINGLE.
SEVENTEEN OH NINE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO SINGLE EIGHTEEN OH TWO I
SEVENTY NOCERA'S UNABLE EIGHTEEN
TEN I SEVENTY NO ZERO LEVEL
EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN I SEVENTY NO
ZERO A SINGLE EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SINGLE EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SIMPLE EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN I
SEVENTY NO. ZERO SINGLE EIGHTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT I SEVENTY NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY NINE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT.
RESOLUTION THIRTY FIVE I SEVENTY
NO ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY SEVEN I
SEVENTY NO ZERO AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY I
SEVENTY NO.
ZERO MR GLORIA MOVES IN MISTER
LOW SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
MAY TWENTIETH AT ONE PM